um dr fauci doubts safety and
effectiveness of russia's new
coronavirus vaccine well bubba's i'll
tell you the truth
dr ouchie fauci i love what you're doing
bob but unfortunately russia beat us
just like they beat us to the moon what
if what if the russian vaccine
is kind of like all the russian
inventions like little
little gadgets that when i was a kid
like the russians in brooklyn would
create these little devices
right that would trick the pay phones
into putting money it was the noise for
the pay phone
so you'd put it to the speaker and it
would sound like yours were going in
yeah so what if the coronavirus is just
sort of like a bootleg version
of it probably is the real vaccine yeah
that like you know is made by the
russian mob
yeah or like they they send you the rush
they send you the russian vaccine it's
just like a dog
just you have to keep it gets smaller
and smaller yeah like a russian doll it
gets small it's stupid listen here's the
truth
is russia probably does have the vaccine
and i don't mind if russia does have
something that's working just give it to
your people first
and then sell it to us if i got to pay a
little bit more on taxes i just want to
get the vaccine or just [ __ ]
make believe everybody has a vaccine so
the [ __ ] country opens again
so we could just i just want to go back
to the gym or maybe russia i don't want
to turn this into computers and cause
into conspiracy cuties but look at my
love yeah you got it
look at my love on the camera in my
lulu's it looks like i have a puss
because for some yeah i've seen your
loaf and i've never asked to see your
love
so that's what's disturbing about you
yeah cuz i never asked to see it but
somehow a video came in the mail you
showed me
you said you were asking me if this is a
rash and i'm not a doctor yeah i sent my
uh
i sent i sent a picture of my love to
joe list the other day
yeah i announced it's what it is um what
if
i don't want to turn this into
conspiracy cuties but what if russia
created the virus in order to create the
vaccine because they already had it
because they knew it was going to be
like a new type of cold world arms race
and they wanted to get there first like
the moon because are we going to have to
[ __ ] do a green screen vaccine now
like we did about the moon landing yeah
russia got there first i guarantee you
here's what's going to happen we're
children look at the way he's sitting
and look at the job that we're doing
joe biden joe biden is going to die
before
november 3rd and kamala harris will be
the presidential nominee and maybe when
that mark that
check it then also uh donald trump
what's going to happen is right around
when biden dies of old age or something
that's a heart attack stuff like that
you know you're going to see the numbers
soar because kamala has been like she's
going to be the next president
that's gonna happen around october 18th
october 19th
halloween october 31st 2020 out of his
back pocket you're going to see donnie t
with the vaccine in america dr fauci is
going to approve it
because he'll kill his [ __ ] family if
he doesn't say he does he's going to
approve it
we're going to get the vaccine trump's
going to win again and the rest is going
to be history so mark my words
clip this that's what it's going to be
benetique shaking her no
girl work girl work and it's going to be
called the trump vaccine just like all
his businesses
100 percent he'll call it vaccine trump
yeah okay
yeah 100 you're currently watching wepa
in the morning this is our live
morning show that we this is what it
might turn into because i'm getting sick
of doing it every day
yeah so if you're watching this because
we're probably we're in the studio so
we're probably going to release this on
youtube if you're watching this
you can you can watch it every day
patreon.com bay ridge boys go
join up also tons of bonus content tons
of bonus content and
it's it's we knew about it but it's
breaking news to the group chat with
debo and my friends dion sanders
has left the nfl network and is working
for bar store
yeah which is what they needed to do
after [ __ ] dave portney
interviewed the president and it became
a trump network the net the way to solve
that is to get show time
to your network is you need a black guy
and then they got deon
yeah well here's the deal if this would
happen like a couple of years ago you
would have said what's going on with
dion's
career what's up with showtime that he's
going to the internet now you're going
like wow the guy's
probably going to make some money now
finally going to make some money he's
finally going to make some money
uh and he'll be able to be himself a
little bit more because dion is
wild yeah dion is one of my favorite
things deon sanders said
ever one of his he goes what do you say
he said seventy percent of the earth is
covered by water
i cover the rest that's what it is
[ __ ] dope
is that yeah and the kid was an amazing
baseball player too yeah he was he
played baseball too
played basically he was a switch hitter
he was by sports
you're a switch hitter too i'm a switch
hitter too cuz yeah cause
i got one eye but i see well yeah you
got what jani
god has a sense of humor because i often
can see into the future with a lot of my
predictions
but i only got one eye we really hope
you enjoyed that
episode whatever it was about this is
just a stock thing that we're taping on
to every episode
so go make sure you rate review us
subscribe uh turn on your notifications
get jiggy with it and go to patreon.com
where things get really wild